regulations on your election as is
customary at these points um
did you ever think you'd be back in
frontline politics no i really didn't
and if you'd asked me that question even
only two months ago
i would almost certainly have said to
you oh don't be silly so why so why then
i mean i've seen some of the stump
speeches and you know
angry i think would accurately describe
them yes i'm frustrated
uh really frustrated um at three
long years of negotiations going
absolutely nowhere and in the end i just
asked myself a straight question i said
how do we get out of this and what is
the best way to get out of this
and i decided how we get out of it uh is
no deal if necessary
and the best way to get out of it was to
join the only party
that was actually committed to that so
how does the brexit party
have any influence on the process that
we're currently going through in terms
of
the fact that there will be a new
conservative leader a new conservative
prime minister and
undeniably they will be the ones pushing
this process forward well i think if you
look at it we've already had a pretty
massive influence i mean first of all
the local elections were a major shock
to the two big parties we weren't even
standing
and people were giving write-in votes on
their ballot papers for us
then came the euro elections and then
today has come
an opinion poll actually putting us in
first place for westminster
now you know all that in six short weeks
of this
party actually being created so i think
we've already
had that impact we're more or less now
obliging whoever leads the conservative
party to say
um that we will leave without a deal if
that is what we have to do
and you know to have done that in six
weeks
is pretty good going you think what we
can achieve in six months
now you say six months i mean i i'm
assuming therefore that you're not of
the opinion that the brexit party will
disappear if we leave without a deal on
the 31st of october
i don't think we'll disappear for one
very good reason i don't think anybody
at the moment trusts the politicians
i think we would want to see first of
all that there was no reneging on that
secondly that there was no attempt to
water it down
in some way but that we did actually
leave convincingly
cleanly and then build a relationship
with the eu
on equal terms but in terms of the anger
of the frustration that the brexit party
is very clearly tapped into now
if if you didn't create the anger no
one's suggesting that wouldn't you
at least accept that the brexit party
perhaps threw a bit of petrol on the fl
on the fire
the language the rhetoric that was used
you know speakers like yourself
and that that very angry performance
that that you were putting on for
for what i have to say were pretty much
adoring crowds i think you have to face
the fact that the nation's pretty angry
um that is that is why uh it's turned
against the two main parties it's angry
with the fudge
angry with the obfuscation my former
party's gone mad
it's now got 12 twelve
sorry thirteen thanks to the team yeah
thirteen
candidates for the leadership i mean
spare me
uh and so what we have we have okay we
have tapped into a vein of anger and
frustration but
it's for a very clear aim it's to get us
out of the eu
and deliver what the people asked for
there were 17.4 million votes to leave
the european union
there were a bit more than 5 million
votes for the brexit party that by my
reckoning is about 12 million
angry frustrated brexit voters that
couldn't be bothered to go to the
polling station
well i think first of all a lot of
people might have thought you know small
parties don't have a chance now they
know differently
um they know that the brexit party
really can deliver this it's not just
something we're saying
so i think you'll find that our support
goes on increasing as that opinion poll
showed today for all the for all the
talk of no deal and you're right to say
that it has been pushed to the top of
the agenda for many a conservative
leadership
by the brexit party indeed but for all
they talk about it being an option
i mean it was the one thing that was
ruled out
by the leave campaign during the
referendum as you well know
and it was defeated by only one vote
in parliament and that vote by a labour
mp uh who appeared wearing a tag
so let's be very clear that parliament
itself which is 70
hang on 75 remain wasn't so very keen
and so very clear about ruling out a no
deal
and the more we have failed to get a
deal the more people are saying
right if we can't get a deal let's just
end this process
i mean we keep hearing about democratic
deficits and betrayal of the people but
wouldn't
wouldn't the biggest betrayal be that
the 17.4 million people who voted to
leave the european union
were told all the way through that
process that leaving without a deal
was not a possibility was not even an
option
wouldn't pushing for the thing that they
vote did not vote for the one thing they
didn't vote for
wouldn't pushing isn't that isn't that
the greatest betrayal if you actually
look at the last
uh european elections wasn't that long
ago is your memory will be quite fresh
we were actually saying leave without a
deal
and we topped the poll now that was a
democratic exercise that reaffirmed the
people's vote
of 2016. if we had stood there and said
we're not leaving without a deal
and we had topped the poll you could do
devise nothing from it
but you can derive from what happened
that people now
want out when are we going to get a
brexit party benefit manifesto then
well you'll get that for a general
election but let me say this i think
no no no no i want to finish i'm sorry
no that's not that's right
and i said you'll get that for a general
election and you will
i think niger this was what i was
wanting to say to you i think nigel
farage was absolutely right to resist
the pressure for a manifesto and for
broad range of policies in the euro
elections for this reason
we had but one policy which was leave
without a deal
and that so took us to the top of the
poll and nobody can say
oh they voted for you for other reasons
come on we had one policy no the remains
we've had the reason you do not have a
manifesto today is it is impossible
for the 29 meps to agree on a policy
platform of course it is all we have to
judge you on is what you have said in
the past
martin dobney claire fox yourself come
from
massive parts of the place and what
attribute it is to nigel farage
that he's put together that broader
spectrum now you say it is impossible
it is being tried now we are entering
upon that process now
and by the time we fight a general
election whether it's in three months or
six months or three years we don't know
we will have a full range of policies
and we
will be able to unite around them the
reason the reason i push on this point
is frankly there are there are policy
positions
that you have suggested in the past
that martin daubney clear fox others
would have real difficulty
advocating or indeed standing next to
someone who was forced to i mean
you wrote a newspaper column in 2012
where you talked again about gay
conversion therapy
you suggested that the unhappy set
homosexual should according to gay
activists
be denied any chance whatsoever to
investigate any possibility
of seeing if he can be helped to become
heterosexual
now i don't even need to ask you whether
or not that's still your view the fact
that you expressed it means
that plenty of people would not want to
share a platform with you
and i also pointed out that there was a
time when we thought it was quite
impossible for men to become women
and vice versa and the fact that we now
think it is quite impossible
for people to switch sexuality doesn't
mean that science may not yet produce an
answer at some stage that was
the thruster no i'm just going to be
clear you are saying that there's a
possibility that science
can change sexuality i don't know any
more than people once knew whether it
was possible for men to become women
i don't know and i've never claimed and
this is where i'm misrepresented quite
often
i've never claimed that such science
already exists i've never claimed that
i've merely said that if you simply rule
out the possibility of it
you're denying people who are confused
about their sexuality or discontented
with it
the chances that you do give to people
who want to change gender and that's all
i've said
i do not imagine for one moment that the
brexit party
will be putting forward a policy on gay
sex
changes in its manifesto we have health
we have it i suspect it will have a
policy
you're just completely looking for
things
that actually do not determine people's
votes what determines people's votes are
the big policies
and we will have that and while you're
talking about standing on the same
platform as claire fox
uh she has said in the past some things
uh which might be interpreted as giving
aid and sucker to the ira indeed i left
a darn good i lost a darn good friend in
the brighton bomb
i myself missed it by 20 minutes i can
stand on a platform with her
because we're united in our aim to get
britain out of the eu and in case
anybody out there is forgetting it
that is the aim of the brexit party we
want to get
a free independent proud britain
and we want to leave that to our
children and our children's children
i have a strong suspicion that no one
will be forgetting that ann whitaker
many thanks for joining us